[Music]
what the heck is that
it's the end of the world
well that's it for me i'm glad it's you
chunky
the world's first family searches for
the perfect place to call home in the
delightful family friendly comedy the
croods a new age
as they embark on an epic house hunting
adventure they discover new lands
encounter strange creatures and meet
their biggest challenge yet
another family whoa where did another
family come from in prehistoric times
here's everything you need to know
before you watch the croods a new age
so what exactly happened to them before
this movie even begins
when we saw them in their feature film
debut the croods the loving family lives
in a prehistoric age filled with
dangerous creatures and earth-shaking
events
faced with the end of the world as they
knew it they were forced to leave home
aided by a stranger named guy played by
ryan reynolds who became a part of their
family as they survived a bonkers period
in their lives
the croods are a tight-knit family who
like to do everything together
courageous and loyal they're led by the
very protective grug played by nicholas
cage
and the supremely supportive ugga played
by katherine keener
their oldest daughter eep voiced by emma
stone and her inventive boyfriend guy
are always itching for independence
while their son thunk and
ugga's mother grand try everyone's
patience as often as possible
i thought cave people died off years ago
we
happy meet you
thanks but what about the other family
that the croods meet
known as the betterments phil hope and
their daughter don are hip and modern
at least for the time period in which
they live in they reside together in a
sprawling treehouse and live happily off
their land
munching on fresh produce thanks to the
irrigation system they've installed of
course
surrounded by their own amazing
inventions and powered by their own
vivid imaginations
they look like super powered versions of
guy when he first met the croods
and it's not just their appearances
either but their attitudes towards life
and inevitable challenges that arise
resolving their differences and learning
to live with them are one thing
but another huge challenge awaits that
promises to change
everyone's lives yet again the croods
and new age will be brighter and even
more colorful showcasing the especially
wondrous fruits and vegetables that have
been formed by the betterments and
allowing more members of the supporting
cast to shine including the lovable
creatures who joined the croods on their
last adventure
we also anticipate that the friendship
between eep and dawn the first ever for
the similar age teenage girls
will reap some surprising results for
both families
so now you know and now you can go watch
the croods a new age
you